[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We
welcome Manuel Bronstein,
VP of Product Management
here at Google,
to talk to us about the next
generation Google Assistant.
Manuel, thanks for joining us.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Thanks
for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
let's go really big picture
for a moment.
When you think about how
the Google Assistant changes
peoples' everyday lives for the
better, what does it look like?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah, so when
we thought about the product,
we want it to be--
our mission is to be the
best way to get things done.
And when we say best, we
think about seamless, fastest,
easiest way to get things done.
And if you think about a
world, in some ways it's
getting more complex, right?
Every time you try
to do something,
you need to think about not
only what you want to do,
but the how.
And if we do our
job right, and we're
investing to make
it happen, you want
to be able to go from "Why
do I want to get done?"
to getting it done without
having to worry about the "how"
in many ways.
And our hope is that
that saves you time.
And we all know how
important it is for all of us
to get a little bit more time
to do all the things that we
care about.
So we're very proud
to be investing
in making the
product the best way
to get things done, in many
ways to give users time back.
EMILY FORTUNA: So the
Assistant is becoming
more and more personalized.
How does that help us as well?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: So
think about-- when
people think about
an Assistant, they're
thinking about a
product that it's
going to learn from them,
that is going to understand
what they're saying.
And in order for the system to
understand what you're saying,
it needs to understand
your role, right.
If I say, "Call my wife."
It needs to know that my wife
is [? Arianna ?] and what number
to call.
If I say, "Set an
appointment for my kids."
It should understand
who my kids are.
So when the Assistant
starts getting to know you,
or even knows where is
home, where is work,
so that I can go,
hey, when I'm asking
it to give me a direction, I
said like, "Drive me work."
It can understand that.
This is something that becomes
more useful because you
can speak to it in
a more natural way.
You don't have to
think about addresses
or you don't have to
think about commands.
You just speak to
it the same way
you would speak to a
friend, and then it
will understand
what you're trying
to do and help you get it done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is
your favorite new feature
that Assistant announced
today, and why?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: I mean it's
really hard to pick a favorite.
The team worked really, really
hard on many of the things
that we announced today.
I think that when you
think about the promise
of the Assistant being the
best way to get things done,
when it starts
getting really fast,
and what we announced with
the next-generation Assistant,
and one of the key
things about it--
and we're saying it in
a very proud way, which
is, imagine that it starts
understanding you so fast, so
quickly, that speaking to your
phone is faster than tapping.
Or that tapping your phone
is going to feel slow.
That's when you know
that you hit something
that could change
your user behavior
and get people to start
embedding themselves
into this product.
Because it's actually
becoming very simple, but also
very fast and very
efficient in helping you
get your tasks done.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's great.
So in the past couple
of years, we've
seen Assistant play
a much larger role
in homes and phones.
And now in driving.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Right.
EMILY FORTUNA: So
can you tell us
about the experience for
drivers and what that's like?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah.
You know, I mean, when you
think about using your voice
and being hands-free--
actually, you know, the car is
a perfect environment for it,
right?
Hopefully people are driving
and they're looking at the road,
they're not looking
at their phones,
they're not touching the screen.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hands-free driving.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's hands
on wheel, not on the phone.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Correct.
So when you can think
about it, actually the car
is one of the places
where the system can
be even more helpful, right?
But the car is a
hard environment
because if your windows are
down, there's a lot of noise,
you may lose connectivity,
and so forth.
But one of the things
that we started
thinking about is let's
start from the user,
and what is that
thing that you're
trying to get done when
you're in your car?
And there are mainly
three things, right?
You're trying to
navigate from point A
to point B. You want to
get to the place hopefully
fast and safe.
You also want to make sure
that when you're in the car
you can get entertained.
So you want to listen to
music or podcast or radio.
And then of course you sometimes
want to communicate, right.
You want to make
a phone call, you
want to receive a text message,
or send a text message.
And think about doing all
these things with your hands
while you're driving,
it's probably not
the right way to do it.
It's not safe.
But when you start doing
each of these scenarios,
like driving from
point A to point B,
communicating, or
listening to media,
and you can control
that with your voice
and it understands exactly
what you're trying to get done,
then the product
becomes very magical
because it's really solving a
real need and a real problem
in an environment
that needs that help.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Can you talk to us
about how the next generation
of the Google Assistant
will change the way that
people interact with it?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
Yeah, so if you
think about when you start
forgetting about the how,
and you start worrying about
what is it that you want to do,
you start relying on the
product in a very different way.
That's when the behavior
change starts to happen, right?
So in the first phase
of the Assistant,
it should be very
responsive to you, right?
It should understand
what you're saying
and then help you get it done.
As the product starts
learning from you,
you can start getting
more proactive, right.
So now when I get
in my car it can
flash to me some missed calls
or voicemails that I have,
so that if I want
to return that call,
I'm reminded of that, right?
Or if it knows
that in my calendar
I have an appointment at 7:00
PM and it's 6:00 PM or 6:30
and I haven't left, and it also
knows information of where I'm
trying to go, and
knows the traffic,
it could actually
send me a notification
and let me know,
hey, you're probably
going to be a late if
you don't leave now.
And it's very interesting
when the product
starts getting more proactive.
I think that we're
going to see a switch.
I mean, I see it a
lot with my kids.
In the same way that when the
screens became touch screens,
and people felt that
every screen is touchable,
and you see a little kid
and they see an old TV
and they try to
touch on the screen,
and the screen doesn't work.
I think that people
are going to get used
to talking to their products.
And expecting that
the product will
understand what you're saying
in a natural way and help you
get it done.
And I think that we're
going to see that evolution
from basically understanding
your commands, what you want
to do and help you get it done,
to getting very proactive,
personal, and more helpful.
So anticipating your
needs and the things
that you're trying
to accomplish.
EMILY FORTUNA: So you've got
Assistant on your phone, home,
and now driving.
Where do you see Assistants
going in the future?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: So
it's a great question.
Look, I think that a personal
assistant needs to be with you.
So of course a lot of the
work the team has been doing
is making sure that the
product is available
where you need it the most.
I don't know necessarily
that it's going
to go to different places.
I mean, at the end of the day,
we spend time in our homes,
we spend time at work, we
spend time in our cars,
we spend time with our phones.
Maybe too much time
with our phones.
But if the product can
always be with you,
then it can help you fulfill
some of those things.
I think that in the future,
what I'm hoping it helps--
I mean, if you think
about the areas
where people spend time
trying to get things done,
but they wish that--
when I think about it, when
you want to go to a restaurant,
the act of going
to the restaurant
and having a nice
meal is awesome.
Maybe calling to make a
reservation is not that great.
But if this product can start
doing those things for you
and remove that load from you,
it becomes incredibly useful.
So I think that if you think
about more of those tasks
that people are trying to get
done, and help you anticipate
it, find that ticket
for an event for you
that you want to go to, making
that appointment for you,
and getting predictive
about those things,
then the product becomes
extremely magical.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Before you leave us,
are there any hints you can
give us to find some Easter
eggs in the Assistant?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Sure.
We recently launched a new
voice for the Assistant
with John Legend.
And it's pretty cool.
And if you asked-- actually, if
you turn the voice to the John
Legend voice on the
Assistant and you
ask it to sing a song for
you or sing happy birthday,
you are going to hear John
Legend singing for you.
And it's actually pretty cool.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Thank you, Manuel,
so much for sharing
your insight.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
So great to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]